das wort bewegen ist ganz interessant im
deutschen man kann etwas physisch
bewegen ich bewege das mikrofon oder
etwas kann einen emotional bewegen oder
gedanklich bewegen
janisch was bewegt dichten gerade jetzt
in diesem moment in diesem moment bewegt
mich meine angst diese frage zu stellen
weil ich selber diesen wort glaube ich
nicht so ganz verstehe und ich hoffe
dass ich gleich in zwei stunden das wort
und diesen begriff besser verstehen ich
kann mir allerdings nicht vorstellen was
die leute wirkliche antworten darauf ich
habe ein bisschen peinlich dass sie dann
reagieren so was meinst du
aber vielleicht nicht vielleicht
verstehen sie diesen begriff besser als
ich so dass ich bin gespannt janisch
fragt jetzt auf der straße was bewegt
dich gerade oder im allgemeinen
los gehts los geht's
[Musik]
hier ja nciht ein mikrofon
was bewegt dich heute was mich bewegt
ich habe erst vor kurzem studienplatz
bekommt eine relativ renommierten uni
und es freut mich da war ich jetzt auch
gerade eben das ist in potsdam
da war ich mir so ein transponder chip
abholen für die eingangstür gezeichnet
was leckeres zu essen gehört um das
quasi zu feiern mit meiner freundin und
ja das ist so zieht nicht was mich heute
30 gratulation
dank was wirst du studieren cyber
security also zum einen bewegt mich
heute die wohnungssuche für meine
freundin und dann dass ich ihr diese
blumen gekauft habe das bewegt mich mich
bewegt dass ich zu besuch bin in berlin
und meine freundin besucher und ja das
finde ich ganz toll
heute bewegt mich der beginn vom
frühling irgendwie also wenn ich so um
mich herum schaue dann sehe ich schon
die ersten knospen bei den bäumen oder
eben die ersten blätter sprießen und
auch einige blumen also das finde ich
sehr schön und auch der sonnenschein
ja mich bewegt meine frisur
ich habe eine frist hinten und das ist
schön dass man ist etwas über fertig
nach dem chor ohne zeit und dann war's
erst mal bewegt mich gerade aktuell
bewegen mich so debatten um entweder
sexualisierte gewalt oder dieses ding
mit dem pinken handschuhe diese perioden
sache wie heißt die kampagne ist eine
kampagne die von männern gestartet wurde
um perioden produkte zu entsorgen und es
ist so sehr abwegig alles ja solche
themen was bewegt ich heute jetzt gerade
bewegt mich meinen spaziergang durch den
prenzlauer berg durch den ganzen tag im
home-office gesessen habe und man sich
manchmal in der korona zeit fragt ob die
welt um einen herum noch existiert und
dann tut es gut mal raus zu gehen dass
das sind die gedanken mit denen ich
jetzt gerade hier den spaziergang machen
dass ich mich schön fühlen
keine ahnung dass ich jetzt vor vier
tagen geburtstag hatte und ich spüre
gerade wie alle mich lieben und das
bewegt mich mich bewegt heute der
ausgleich zwischen arbeit und uni und
freizeit und das alles auf einmal
hinzukriegen auch während der back down
zeit positive energie das ist mir
wichtig ja und da der tag ist schön ein
bisschen zu kalt mich bewegt eigentlich
dass es noch ein bisschen zu kalt ist
für die im april ansonsten ist alles gut
kunst und kultur
das ist eine starke bewegung würde ich
auch sagen ja es ist während wir dieses
video gedreht haben ist uns aufgefallen
dass dieses werk bewegen ganz
unterschiedlich übersetzt werden kann
und deshalb seht ihr auch in unserem
untertiteln in dieser episode manchmal
unterschiedliche übersetzungen bewegen
kann etwas ganz tiefes emotionales sein
und dann können wir es auf englisch mit
todtmoos übersetzen
aber es kann auch eher oberflächlich und
unwichtig sein und dann seht ihr
vielleicht watch on your mind als
übersetzung und was bewegt sie im leben
so allgemein im leben das ist wirklich
die familie das ist der kern aller dinge
für mich ganz einfach die liebe zu
menschen ja was ich nicht das streben
nach irgendwas dass ein fröhlich macht
auf lange sicht und zufrieden stellt
also nichts
speziell ist bereitet den angenehmen
beruf leute die man kennt um sich herum
zu haben die einem freude bereiten
das also nichts spezielles mal eher
allgemein vielleicht zu die zeit wie die
zeit vergeht
manchmal kommt es aber so vor als würde
die zeit so richtig langsam vergehen
also müsste man nicht was man so am tag
macht also dass man einfach so versucht
die zeit so dass man halt die zeit zu
versucht weiter zu bringen oder so dass
man eben sich irgendetwas sucht wie man
die zeit halt überbrücken kann
und manchmal denke ich
61 genau und dann denke ich mir auch
manchmal so war die letzten zwei wochen
sind so schnell vergangen
das ist schon wahnsinn
[Musik]
übrigens wusstet ihr dass ihr zu all
unseren videos auch transkripte vokabel
listen und interaktive übungen bekommen
könnt alles was ihr machen müsst ist ein
mitglied zu werden von easy german damit
unterstützt sie auch unsere arbeit und
das geht beim patchen dot com / german
[Musik]
und wo nehmen sie die kraft dafür die
kraft in der innerliche sache sie dürfen
sich nicht ablenken lassen müssen sich
immer darauf konzentrieren eine
innerliche sache ganz ganz normal kraft
um reich zu sein brauche ich jetzt nicht
groß aber sie kommt einfach von besetzt
meine familie und meine freunde
definitiv und natürlich auch jetzt so
der frühling und der sommer weil im
winter und im herbst finde ich
vielleicht ein bisschen ein bisschen
mehr antriebslos also in der hellen ja
in der hellen jahreszeit zum beispiel
jetzt was gibt ihnen kraft was gibt
tatsächlich gibt mir auch der job ein
bisschen kraft ja so war musste man muss
schon etwas machen wo man spaß daran hat
ja was ist was arbeit ist in informatik
herren manager
also ich mache meine eigene firma und
das ist toll das ist ein abenteuer
es ist fantastisch kein fernseher
schauen das ganz wichtig bei mir die
nachrichten im internet kein fan sind
schon fernsehen lenkt sie viel zu viel
abgeführte viel zeit für mich absolut
ich bin im moment kämpfe ich damit dass
ich nicht so viel youtube.de ich bin da
youtube guter ja auch zu viel das ist
auch das lenkt nur ab
wie soll ich sagen dass das das frisst
zu viel zeit für ihr eigenes leben war
ich glaube die kommt einfach so mussten
wir die gar nicht wollen ich habe dir
einfach in mir
die kommt von innen
und hiervon nicht passt was gibt die
hoffnung wirklich alles sehr sehr
philosophisch es gibt mir hoffnung dass
es viele gute menschen auf dieser welt
gibt
obwohl vieles nicht gut läuft
kenne ich doch genug menschen die ja ein
gutes herz haben was gutes wollen
man muss sich einfach bewegen habe
solange man in bewegung bleibt wird wird
sich es schon alles fügen üblicherweise
hoffnung geben wir zum beispiel
demonstrationen oder auch bücher
vielleicht auch schöne filme hoffnung
geben mir vor allem die mit menschen die
ich jeden tag dabei erlebe wie sie
versuchen irgendwie so ihre umwelt ein
bisschen besser zu machen ob das durch
politischen aktivismus ist oder dadurch
dass sie einander helfen oder was auch
immer ich würde sagen wenn es
irgendetwas gibt was aktuell hoffnung
gibt dann ist es das so irgendwie
hoffnung gibt mir dass viele vielleicht
sachen nicht so ernst nehmen
ja vielleicht ja nicht alles so
kleinkariert sehen und ich umgebe mich
mit leuten die nicht so so steif in
ihren ansichten sind
und ja das gibt mir hoffnung dass die
gesellschaft immer bunter wird in den in
den denkweisen in vielen bereichen ja
also ich hätte jetzt das gegenteil
gesagt dass es mir hoffnung gibt dass
immer mehr bereiche immer mehr
diskutiert werden und eben nicht alles
gesagt werden also natürlich gilt ja
noch die meinungsfreiheit aber dazu
rassistische und sexistische kommentare
und witze einfach nicht mehr aktuell
sind und immer mehr darüber gesprochen
wird
naja ich gesagt ich nehme die hoffnung
dadurch dass es mir dadurch keine
gedanken mache ich gesagt ich bin ganz
gut verdrängen
und woher nehmen sie die hoffnung dass
alles gut gehen dies gab dir mal ein
gefühl das ist das bauchgefühl sagte
ihnen alles im prinzip dass alles gut
wird wenn sie positiv eingestellt sind
dann klappt das aber wir sind natürlich
immer mit dem native leuten umgeben sind
und die wollen nicht und das mag ich
nicht und haben auch nichts los und so
gerne das trifft sie selber auf sie
müssen sich selber immer wieder
aufbrechen das alles das man rezept
jetzt wollen wir von euch wissen was
bewegt euch denn im moment schreibt uns
mal einen kommentar hier auf deutsch
damit verbessert ihr euer deutsch und
übt weiter deutsch und wenn ihr noch
mehr üben möchte dann werdet doch gerne
ein mitglied von the german bei patchen
dot com / german dann bekommt ihr zu
diesem videos und zu allen anderen
videos transkripte und interaktive
übungen tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]